do you think this documentaries been
unfair to Pippin do you think it's
making him the fall guy so originally
when he said that I thought no okay
you know it seems like no two things one
somebody on Twitter I should find the
name but he said Pippins when Pippin had
the migraine series against the Pistons
and he lost his dad died around that
same time like May 2nd 1990 the
documentary didn't really bring up oh
Pittman's dealing with the death of his
father
it's migraines and it's Jordan being
like I mean he says he has migrant but
Jordans dad died it's like yeah I lost
those two Finals games because I had a
lot my dad died three years ago dad died
three weeks ago max maybe during the
series and you're just like yeah I don't
know migraines Berg grow up like yeah he
talking about that so maybe you and Mike
will bond brought this up after
SportsCenter if Phil dare draw up a
final play that went to Pippen do you
think MJ would have handled it well back
when MJ was planned no but but did he he
had that play he's like yo if what's his
face is open give it to him except if
he's open the ball goes to you but and
then you make the phone and you make the
final decision if he's open kick it out
I will say this just go back to it being
unfair Pippen I think it is unfair
Pippen because these things that have
happened throughout history that they're
touching on with Pippen like the 1.8
seconds left etc don't really play a
larger role right yeah they hit that
shot but then they ended up losing yeah
so it seems like I understand if you hit
that shot then you go to the finals and
you win the finals yeah you must include
that in the legacy that's very important
but hand selecting random games where
yeah Pippen did something and then they
either wanted a lost but it really
didn't affect the legacy of the Bulls as
we know it it actually plays no part
whatsoever and the story besides just
showing that Scottie Pippen was kind of
selfish like the contract nonsense and
but I think that's important to show
because it's like it shows his mentality
as a person and that carries on to the
court like if you that's a bit weak in
my opinion yes
when you let your emotions get the best
of you that much it was we agree I think
he also I think they'll say this I think
that they do it to position Jordan as
the alpha and I think what I think the
lesson for Pippen was I'm not insecure
about being second fiddle to Jordan
because I know he's better than me yeah
I'll wear his sneakers and ask for him
to come back I don't think
Kukoc is better than me but my greatest
insecurity right now is that the
organization does that the players
around me do and it maybe the fans do so
when everybody sees he gets to take the
last-second shot instead of me it
confirms my greatest insecurity which is
this other guys better than me when they
to Jordan's take a last shot or choose
Jordan to do some commercial for the
Bulls or choose door to anything it's
like you know what they should cuz he's
actually that much better than me I can
live with that hmm I just think if you
don't have those moments to be filmed
than to come up in this documentary we
wouldn't see any of them so this is like
that he has so many of those moments him
throwing the chair out of frustration
and [ __ ] like that I'm like who there's
a moment where Pippen throws a chair and
they slaps teammates like it but that's
insane
they highlight those bad quality you're
saying is unfair to him no I think it
just paints a full picture change the
full picture I think a lot I think I
don't know if it's that deep with
positioning Jordan is the Alpha I think
a lot of this is just Jordan wanting to
explain things away
yeah the gambling I gamble but I didn't
have a problem like they talk about all
his problems and then he gets to address
him
this isn't patrons documentary so they
actually kind of I think Jordan kind of
threw him a bone with listen let's
explain that everybody on the team
forgave you after you didn't go into
that play so they get full context that
you owned it right away you apologize to
the team you got emotional let's explain
all that but that's pretty much after
that we don't really need to worry about
you yeah the migraines I thought that
was [ __ ] yeah I mean if Jordan had
migraines during a Game seven
you don't think there'll be a full
[ __ ] episode but they big them up
they big up Pippen throughout this whole
[ __ ] also my best player oh he's a the
greatest players
no fair I don't think the prepared job
yeah but this it's the purposes
documentary I think is a lot of Jordan
mean like let me explain myself
it's a sneaker commercial and it's I'm
gonna explain myself for the last time
in history because I'll now much longer
on to be here and I want to make sure
that I decide what history is gonna look
like from now moving on
[Applause]